hey welcome to the ultimate tent review
video we have 13
tents here of every shape size price
range and color
and we're gonna walk you through how to
pick the right tent for you
despite what some people say you don't
need to spend
a lot of money to get a good tent but
there is a time
and a place to spend four five six
hundred dollars on a tent
i just want to make sure that you spend
money only when you need to spend money
so first off let me start you off with
the basic
three-man tent
yep
this tent right here is the walmart
brand ozarks trail
three-man dome tent it costs only 25
and this is a perfectly good tent
it does a lot of things really well they
say it's a three-man tent it's really
two adults or
uh an adult and two kids you can put
three people in here but you'll have no
room to move and no room for your gear
it's a very
tight fit they're also surprisingly
durable
i've had this tent and used it many
times and just i've had no problems with
it
if you go to walmart or you go online
you'll find a bajillion companies that
sell
seven foot by seven foot three man tents
and they range from 25 to 50 bucks
they're all
pretty much the same design with few
variations
and they're all perfectly good tents
this one
i bought for 30 like 17 years ago
they're between
five and a half to six and a half pounds
and they're just
good all around tents and my attitude is
that you should start with one of these
tents unless there's a good reason
not to and there's only a few reasons
why
you need anything more than this one is
you need something bigger you just got
more people this isn't going to fit your
needs or maybe you're of an age where
you're just sick and tired
of having to crawl into a tent and hunch
over when you get dressed
these also are not that great in winter
they're okay but not great
and in really harsh conditions these
tents
don't hold up that well there's a couple
things to look at
with these tents first off is the rain
fly how much of the tent is covered by
the rain fly
the further down the rain fly goes the
better this is going to hold up in
extreme conditions and in cold weather
additionally
look at the bottom the material on the
wall should not be the same material as
the bottom you want like a tarp like
material
on the bottom if you don't have a really
thick
sturdy bottom you're going to need to
buy a ground tarp
and lay that down or you're just going
to have moisture come up through the
tent or you're going to tear a hole in
the bottom of your tent so these nice
cheap tents
come with reinforced bottom so you don't
need a grand
ground tarp there's also a couple little
features that i really like to see
in these tents this ozark trail tent has
a little spot where you can run a power
cord
in and out of your tent additionally on
the roof i like to see these little
loops
so you can hang stuff you can hang a
lantern up here
hang a little mesh bag up here to store
stuff because there's not a lot of room
in this tent
you should have a little pouch so you
can hold stuff oh look
i found one of my old dsl batteries i
wonder where that went stuff you put
your keys and your cell phone and things
like that so you're not rolling over
them in the night
and some of these tents have windows and
some of them don't this one is just 25
bucks
there's no window so if it's really hot
out you're not going to get much
ventilation
this little swiss sport has two pouches
one for each person to hold their stuff
and it has a rear window
so a little slightly different features
but kind of pick and choose what you
care about
when it comes to picking a tent a lot of
people think that more expensive teds
are higher quality or they're more
durable and it's really not the case
most of these tents are made out of
pretty much the same material and
they're all
really durable this 30 dollar tent
it's lasted me 17 years and i have
abused this thing
um i've never really had a problem with
any of my tents the only thing that ever
seems to break
is the bag the tents come in when you
spend a lot of money on tents
what you're getting is features or
performance that you don't get with
these smaller
cheaper tents you're getting a tent that
can handle the cold
you're getting a tent that has more room
you're getting a tent that's super
lightweight
you're getting a tent that's designed to
do something that these tents don't do
but you're not getting a tent that's
higher quality or
more durable i have never really noticed
a big difference
in the brands of tents it seems like you
get the same thing whether you buy a
name brand or a no-name brand or you get
a coleman or field stream
or eureka or ozark trail it doesn't make
much of a difference i suspect most of
the tents are made in the same factories
in china anyway
these small cheap three-man dome tents
are wonderful
i've got three sleeping bags three mats
three pillows
and a three-man tent with a stove and
some food
all in this little bag everything me and
my boys need to camp
right here in one little bag and this
entire kit
cost me about 300
there's a lot of three-man tents that
cost a lot more than 25 bucks
but generally there's only a few reasons
you should pay more money
for a three-man tent one is lightness
you want a backpacking tent and you want
it to be as light as possible but a
general rule of thumb
is that you're gonna spend 150 bucks for
every pound
you shave off your tent so this is a 5.6
pound tent for 25 bucks
if you want a three pound tent you're
going to spend about 400 bucks
you want a one pound tent you're gonna
spend about 800 bucks
so if you want a lighter tent you're
gonna pay dearly for each pound
that you shave off that tent another
reason to buy an expensive tent is so
that it has more insulation
and better endurance in extreme weather
this tent right here is a good example
of that
this right here is the rei ariat asl2
it's a two-man tent that costs
400. it's 5.5 pounds so only a tenth of
a pound lighter
than the 25 walmart three-man tent
behind me
why is this so expensive well this is
designed
for cold weather high wind extreme rain
the one behind me not so much the main
difference
is the rain fly covers the entire tent
which protects it
from rain and adds a better layer of
insulation that keeps the heat in better
there's also extra poles to keep it
from blowing around or collapsing if
it's got snow on top of it or wind
that sort of thing the stakes are really
rigid they don't bend
and they're just this really strong
super light material
what do you think of this tent is this
cool tim
i want to sleep in it it's so comfy this
tent is the same length as the cheap 25
tent it's just not quite as wide i just
stand up
it's really a one-man tent with a little
bit of extra room
or a very cozy two-man pet this tent has
the vent in the top there
and a vent there that you can zip open
or close to let heat out if it's too
warm
but there's no windows in here you can't
get much cross ventilation in this tent
so it's going to be really stuffy
if you're in hot weather additionally
the floor in this tent is kind of thin
they recommend you use a ground tarp
with this tent
which is an added expense which is added
weight
you can get by without it but you
increase the chance of wearing out the
floor of your 400
tent and it increases the chance that
you get moisture up through the floor
the only reason you should buy this tent
is if you are going to be in extreme
wind
cold and rain if you're not that kind of
camper
get the 25 tent this tent is not more
durable
or longer lasting than the 25 tent it's
the same thin stuff if you poke this
with a stick you will put a hole in it
if you step on the poles at night you
will break them
just like the 25 tent
this is the alps one man mountaineering
tent it's about a hundred dollars
and it's basically a small portable
coffin
it is small
smaller tents are warmer tents the less
volume of air you have inside your tent
the more your body heat will warm it up
so this smaller one-man tent will be
warmer
than an equivalent three-man tent if you
just got one person in it this
isn't a particularly expensive tent it's
about a hundred dollars
and it's got pretty decent insulation
and extreme weather protection not as
good as the 400
rei tent but pretty good
if you're looking for a compromise
between the 25 walmart tent and the 400
rei tent something like this alps
mountaineering tent
would do the job you've got a rain fly
that goes all the way to the ground
that increases your resistance to rain
wind and cold by a huge amount
this has a lot more ventilation than the
rei
tent uh and you can't close off the
vents
in here like you can with the rei tent
so that's gonna
make it suffer a little bit in cold
weather but make it a little bit nicer
in warm weather
because it's a one-man tent you get a
lot less weight
for less cost really that's the only
reason you ever buy
a one-man tent is to get something
that's lighter without paying
a gob more money all right this is the
inside there's just barely enough room
to lay down in
and just enough room to sit up in but
that
is it you have to store your backpack
under the rain fly because there is no
room inside
there's all mesh here up in the the top
and you can't seal this off so without
the rain fly you have no privacy
and unlike the 400 rei tent you can't
seal off the vents
to make it warmer and there's even a
little peekaboo window so you can see if
there's a bear attacking you or
something
all right now let me show you a couple
specialty tents these two tents behind
me are carp fishing bivvies
made by an english company called fox
this is the fox r series two man vivi
that's the fox royal one man bivvy these
are specifically designed for fishermen
who want to fish
day in and day out for multiple days and
they want to camp by their rods
and they want the ultimate in four
season ruggedness
and luxury if you want to be comfortable
no matter what the weather
these are the ultimate tents and while
these are specifically designed for
fishermen
you don't have to be a fisherman to
appreciate a lot of these features
these are versatile durable and always
comfortable
well look at this thing this is what fox
calls a two-man bivvy
this thing is massive i'm almost six and
a half feet tall
and look at this i mean
that's uh that's spacious one of the
things that's nice about these bivvies
is the doors and windows are extremely
versatile
you can get rid of the whole front of
the bivy if you want open up these back
windows and get tons of airflow in here
and this is a nice cool place to get out
of the heat if it's really hot but you
have bugs you can do this fine mesh over
the windows and doors
or if it's cold you can replace the mesh
with this clear vinyl door
and that way you can see outside at
what's going on in your fishing rods
while staying warm inside or if you
prefer privacy you can put on the solid
door
and then you can open it up letterbox
style
and you can just there you go
just have it slightly open so you can
still see what's going on
without letting too much hot air out
the nice thing about these tents is the
doors are designed with velcro
and zippers so you can burst out your
tent very quickly
if you need to run to get to your
fishing rods
these bivvies are designed to be used
with cots if you like to sleep on a cot
get a sleeping bag that attaches to the
cot
this one has a strap around the middle
and it's got this part
up here that slides over the top
and over the foot and it keeps the bag
attached to the cot so when you roll
over you get in and out you don't have
to constantly
adjust your bag it will do more to
improve your sleep
than anything else the floor of this
bivvy is removable and i almost
never use it i find it really annoying
because you just track dirt into your
bivy all the time and you have to clean
it out the stakes on these bivvies hold
really well
and are really beefy these bivvies have
a lot more stake down spots
this one comes with 16 stakes and 16
spots to stake it
you don't need any guy wires and this
makes it very strong even in very high
winds
other than their size these are almost
the identical bivvy the only difference
is this one has rear windows
and this one does not these bivvies are
really durable i've owned this one for
over six years
it's never given me any problems very
versatile very good four season
all-weather tent
this is the eureka copper canyon eight
man
tent but in our home we refer to it as
tentropolis
come on in this tent has the highest
ceiling
of any tent i've ever seen it's seven
foot four inches
tall i'm six foot four inches so i
wanted something
with head room and we got it this thing
is amazing it comes with a little
divider that you can put here to make it
into two rooms if you want kids over
here
mom and dad over there you can do that
it's got tons of windows
every wall has a window that zips down
um
and you need it because if it's a kind
of a hot day it gets really stuffy in
here pretty quick
this tent has loads of ventilation which
makes it great when it's hot in the
summertime
but it makes it a lousy winter time tent
this tent also has a little
zipper here so you can run an extension
cord
out of the tent and hook it up to a
generator or something the ceiling of
this tent has
about a half a dozen of these little
hooks and grommets up here
it's great for hanging lanterns and bags
and keeping stuff
off the floor and out of the way
the tent comes with this little awning
here which is kind of useless in rain
but it's good for keeping the sun off
you if you want to sit in a chair in
front of your tent
if it rains the water goes and drains
back this way
and then comes off the awning straight
into the tent so you don't want to be
using the awning like this if it rains
if you pitch the poles down low
then you can make the water drain off
but
then the awning is kind of in your way i
love this tent it's been a great tent
for our family
but there's a couple big drawbacks first
off it's over 400
it's not a cheap tent secondly it's 39
pounds and it takes up a lot of room
so if you put this in the trunk of your
car it's gonna fill up a good chunk of
it
also this tent is not good in cold
weather
and finally this tent is very
susceptible
to high winds it's a massive profile i
once was camping with this with a troop
of boy scouts and a gust of wind
picked this tent up and threw it 40 feet
even though there was 200 pounds of gear
inside the tent
the stakes that it comes with are just
the standard little tent stakes you get
real cheapo things
get bigger thicker longer stakes also
the bag that comes with this tent is
really flimsy and frankly too small so
i went and bought this duffel bag and
use it instead
it works great i've also seen people use
rollaway bags
and that's freaking brilliant
the coleman 10 man instant cabin it's
almost the same price in almost the same
dimensions
as the 8-man eureka copper canyon
however
it's got the pop-up feature which is
definitely more convenient
quicker the problem is it makes it
wobbly it wants to tip over all the time
and you have to use the guide wires even
in calm weather like today
you get convenience with this but the
downside
is it handles wind not nearly as well as
the more sturdy eureka
so it's a trade-off one of my biggest
pet peeves is tent bags that are too
small and too flimsy the coleman tent
bag
is actually pretty functional and it's
pretty easy to get the tent back in the
bag and it has this strip
you tear it off and the bag gets bigger
and so now it's like a full-size duffel
bag and getting the tent into this bag
is super easy so i really like that
another thing i appreciate is that the
coleman instant cabin comes with the
larger beefier tent stakes
with a big tent like this you need that
the coleman also has a little zipper so
you can run an extension cord through
the tent
so you can see here you've got mesh on
the entire ceiling like you do with most
of these big tents
and you also have windows on all sides
which are great in the summertime for
more ventilation and cooling it down
not so great in the winter time and with
most fair weather tents the rainfly only
comes to the top of the wall
so this part the lower part of the wall
will get wet if it rains a lot and
you'll get moisture soaking through
which is pretty typical i do like that
the guide wires have reflective material
in them so at night these
glow really brightly so you don't
clothesline yourself walking around in
the dark it's a nice little feature
this field and stream eight man cross
vent tent has only a slightly smaller
footprint
than the eureka copper canyon or the
coleman instant cabin it's a very large
tent the biggest difference
is the ceiling height the door is about
the same height and the same
size as the coleman instant cabin so
it's pretty easy to get in and out i
have to duck a little bit
this eight man tent is the same length
as the coleman
and eureka tents i showed you earlier
it's just narrower and has a lower
ceiling
that means that you've got a lot less
head space
but also a much better tent for cool
weather you have fewer vents up here
it's about half vents instead of full
vents like the other tents
and there's just less air in here to
have to warm up
so if you're in a cooler condition this
tent is going to be
a lot warmer than those big drafty box
tents
the rain fly on this tent comes down a
little bit lower
on the walls it sticks out a little bit
more so it'll keep the rain off the
walls
slightly better than the big box tents
additionally because it's domed and has
this sloped sides
this is going to handle high winds much
much better
than these massive box tents that have
these big profiles
there's just a lot less surface area for
the wind to push against
these large eight man dome tents are
great they're about a fourth the cost of
the big box tents
they can handle cold weather rain and
wind
a whole lot better and they're lighter
and smaller
you can see here a good size comparison
of the eight person cross vent by field
and stream
versus the 10 man instant cabin from
coleman
the cross vent is half the weight half
the size
and it's a fourth of the price so it's a
great option
if you don't need just tons and tons of
space
this model like a lot of them has a
couple downsides though
the bag it comes in is ridiculously tiny
and you need to be an origami master to
get the tent back into this bag
additionally the stakes that it comes
with are these
tiny little dinky camping stakes you
really should upgrade
to some better higher quality stakes but
at a hundred dollars
you'll have a lot of leftover money to
buy an extra bag
and buy some better steaks
[Music]
all right coleman claims this is a four
man pet
i gotta tell you i have a hard time not
falling in love with these pop-up tents
okay they're kind of small but they're
cheap and they are
so convenient i bring these along when i
go fishing with the boys
if the weather is kind of iffy and if
the boys get tired or they get cold i
can just pull this thing out
throw it up in the air and poop there's
a tent for them to play in i mean
how convenient is that if you hate
setting up tents
get yourself a pop-up tent there's just
they just
really are awesome enough room for
nathan to roll around in
they got a little pouch but there's no
windows so this is gonna be a little bit
stuffy in hot weather
um not a ton of room for a four man but
it's a spacious three-man tent
and that's it there's no hooks on the
ceiling it's just
really really bare bones but oh it's so
crazy easy to set up and it's cheap
if you guys are looking for a cheap easy
small little tent
you might want to check this out
wow that that's a big head hey
look at that
hop on in there boy
it's got enough room that i can lay down
and sleep
and i could probably fit the two boys in
here in a pinch but it's a tight
three-man
it's a tight three man well this tent
doesn't have a rain fly so it's not
gonna hold up well in
a downpour but it'll do okay in a light
rain it's got these little velcro
windows on the ends
and it's got a zipper window right here
so you can go and unzip this side as
well and get a lot of ventilation
so this is a good good one in in warm
weather
but i mean how simple and easy is that
okay the most challenging thing about
these tents is putting them away
the trick is you pull it together like a
taco okay
got your little taco here then you put
the end of the taco on the ground
and you grab this part
and then then squish it down on itself
and it kind of makes these circles these
rings and then you just go and stack the
rings on top of each other
and boom and then you just put it away
in its
little bag these little pop-up tents are
super light this
three-man tent here weighs about as much
as a 400
backpacking tent the only thing that's
weird about it is it's kind of this
awkward disc
shape but if you can strap it to the
outside of your backpack
it's a really good inexpensive option
for lightweight camping all right guys
let me show you a bit of a specialized
tent here this is
the peapod by kidco it's a toddler
pop-up pen
now the reason why i'm showing you this
fun little ted
is because it is great for sleep
training kids
this tent comes with a mattress
that's inserted into it unlike the other
tent so you have a built-in pad
that's in there you've got windows on
all four sides the fun thing about this
tent is it's great for sleep training
kids you get them used to sleeping in
this in their own bedroom and camping in
the
in the basement and then when you travel
or go camping
it's not scary for them because they're
used to sleeping in the tent you can go
anywhere you want
and the tent's a familiar place
additionally uh it kind of keeps them
contained
so if your kids roll around a lot um you
can put this on a bed and they won't
fall off
and if your kids like to get up and
wander the zippers kind of help keep
them contained a little bit
so it's a nice little option if you're
trying to travel or camp to small kids
if you're looking for an ultra
lightweight super cheap camping setup
look at hammocks this two-person hammock
is 16
on amazon.com right now it weighs 1.1
pounds additionally when you sleep in a
hammock you don't need a sleeping pad
and that saves weight
as well you can save weight by using
nylon straps instead of rope
which is better for the trees and you
can get little tarps
and mosquito netting that can go over
your hammock that's really light and
affordable
as well the only problem with hammocks
is that they are no good in cold weather
but their weaknesses are also their
strength
hammocks are exceptionally great in hot
weather
you get all that circulation and air all
around your body
through the hammock and around you so if
it's really hot and muggy
it's hard to beat sleeping in a hammock
one of the most unique tents i have here
is the three-man hammock tent the
stingray it's also
one of the most expensive it's a little
under 600 bucks but it is a load of fun
the kids kind of think it's like a
portable
trampoline and it allows you to camp in
places you normally couldn't camp on
hills or bogs
wherever you want as long as you've got
trees you can set this thing up
so that makes it really nice but at 19
pounds
it's not exactly a backpacking tent i
did a really fun tent review video with
this tent and i'll put a link in the
description
if you guys want to check that out
thanks for watching we hope you enjoyed
this video if you want to see
some other great camping videos from the
outdoor boys youtube channel
don't forget to check out our 23 best
campfire recipes video i'll put a link
in the description
and check out me and nathan's survival
video where last winter we went out and
built our own shelter
and slept in it thanks for watching guys
have a great day
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
oh crap now i got to take these all down